[Applaudissements]
merci changer les règles du jeu
on vient de voir une histoire de voyages
de rencontres
mais est ce que la grande aventure qu'on
a à vivre aujourd'hui
n'est-elle pas de trouver du sens
trouver du sens à nos vies là ici
maintenant et c'est ce que ted propose
d'ailleurs trouver du sens ça passe par
plusieurs cartes ou et je vais vous
proposer ce soir de jouer un jeu et de
sortir de mettre sur la table plusieurs
cartes
mais avant je vais vous raconter comment
une seule phrase dans ma vie a changé
mes propres règles du jeu alors c'est
pas mal de parler de ça parce qu'à
l'école j'étais un cancre
j'étais une catastrophe j'étais le
parfait contre-exemple j'essayais de
comprendre des choses j'essayais que la
transmission passe et pourtant ça ne
passait pas j'ai tout essayé
et pourtant j'étais curieuse j'avais
soif d'apprendre
dès que je sortais de l'école tous les
soirs je lisais des livres je lisais des
magazines je regardais des documentaires
là mon intérêt était éveillé je connecte
est avec des choses qui me stimulait qui
me rendait heureuse et je sentais
surtout que j'évolue et que je passais à
des étapes supérieures et dès le matin
je me remettais dans la classe avec mes
professeurs et plus rien une catastrophe
ma mère était désespérée chaque neige
passer d'une école à l'autre à la
finlande et humain elle s'est dit bon
cette petite on va un peu là on va lui
mettre des cadres les règles on va le
mettre en pension et là qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai mis une jolie petite
barrette j'avais mon petit uniforme bleu
marine c'était magnifique c'était tout
sauf moi mais j'ai essayé de toutes mes
forces je me suis dit allez dernière
fois on essaie on y va toujours rien et
la directrice de l'école qui était connu
pour être très très sévère et très très
dur au bout de quelques mois me convoque
dans son bureau je me suis dit c'est
fini
je vais encore me faire virer qu'est ce
que je veux dire de la mer et j'arrive
dans son bureau je ferme mon regard
comme ça du chien battu elle me dit
assieds toi je me suis rue là là ça va
être une catastrophe encore qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui va se passer et tout d'un
coup elle s'est littéralement illuminé
elle a posé ses mains sur mes épaules et
elle m'a dit ma petite fille je vais te
donner une clé accroche ton char à une
étoile et tout se passera bien
c'était magique cette phrase c'était
comme une incantation
c'était comme on à cran
génial a été violent
en deux mois
ce
un pari gagné et j'ai commencé à faire
un rêve un rêve absolument génial un
rêve merveilleux récurrents je rêvais
d'une école un peu spécial une école de
mentors une école de mentors qui avaient
tous des super pouvoirs et leurs super
pouvoirs
c'était tout simplement leur passion ils
étaient tous passionnés il savait
transmettre leurs idées leurs
convictions leur expérience mais de
manière joyeuse ludique décomplexée
c'est ça qui me manquait et ce rêve a
été là à côté à mes côtés pendant des
années des années le temps passe et je
suis devenu adulte et c'est une grande
joie pour moi d'être adulte parce que je
me disais ça y est je suis adulte je
peux faire des choses je peux être dans
l'action je peux être dans le concret
j'ai ce pouvoir là et tout d'un coup je
me suis dit mais pourquoi je me
reconnecte pas avec ce rêve d'enfant on
a tous ici dans la salle un rêve
d'enfant qui n'en a pas ok donc 100%
vous avez tous des rêves d'enfants c'est
génial c'est très important on parlait
d'enfants et que les enfants aiment
jouer il faut reconnecter à son rêve
d'enfant essayer de tout faire pour
connecter dans une réalité dans notre
réalité au quotidien et c'est ça le
grand jeu qu'on à faire aujourd'hui
changer les règles du jeu c'est quoi
c'est trouver du sens c'est s'inspirer
c'est admirer et je pense que
l'admiration et la clé que si nous
n'admettrons pas nous ça
on ne pouvait pas choisir on ne
cherchait même pas du sens aux choses
tout nous était imposé
on se mariait avec une personne qu'on
aimait pas on faisait le métier de nos
parents et puis voilà et puis on faisait
comme on pouvait aujourd'hui on choisit
la personne avec qui on est et on
choisit notre métier on choisit d'être
heureux
est-ce qu'on fait des thérapies est ce
qu'on en fait pas on choisit nos hobbies
c'est génial cette liberté la serbie
joue c'est un joyau et je me suis dit hé
bien ce rêve je vais le transformer en
réalité et je vais créer cette école de
mentors et j'ai créé une agence
d'intervenants de speaker comme on a vu
plein ici ce soir des gens inspirants
qui sont venus pourtant m pour partager
sa touche absolument tous les domaines
donc là la petite fille en moi explose
de joie
j'assiste j'organise du coup et
j'assiste à des interventions où
l'impact est présent on sème des graines
et ce qui se passe change la vie de
certaines personnes
et là je me dis que j'ai gagné mon pari
je suis au bon endroit au bon moment et
j'ai tout mis en place pour justement
accomplir ce rêve notamment pour moi ça
c'est une chose mais surtout de partager
sa de partager ses connexions ses
résonances et ce que j'aime là dedans
c'est que ça permet aux gens de
retrouver une cohérence c'est très dur
de retrouver une cohérence
parce qu'aujourd'hui justement plus que
jamais tout va vite
tout bouge on est bombardé
d'informations dans tous les sens et
c'est très dur de se concentrer en se
disant mais finalement moins qu'est ce
que j'aime dans les modèles ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça nous sert de
boussole
ça nous sert de phare même en pleine
tempête
on a notre bateau c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui tout va à gauche tout va à
droite on a du mal et à aller dans un
seul chemin et le fait d'avoir des
modèles de gens inspirants on comprend
mieux qui on est on comprend mieux le
chemin notre chemin et ça c'est quand
même un luxe
monstrueux qu'on a là ici ce soir on a
énormément de chance tous
de transmettre d'apprendre et qui est
cette énergie là qui passe ce qui est
intéressant c'est de partager ça d'être
inspirés par des gens mais ce qu'on ne
sait pas c'est ça aussi qui est
fantastique ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
tous tous les gens tous ici dans cette
salle vous inspirer d'autres personnes
mais on est beaucoup trop timide
on n'ose pas le dire nous mêmes quand on
admire des gens des qualités ou des
talents chez les gens autour de nous ça
peut être un cercle très intime
ça peut être des gens qu'on a croisé
trois fois mais on dit waouh sept
personnes à tel talent telle qualité
c'est génial j'aimerais tellement lui
ressembler on n'ose pas assez dire à
tous ces gens là tu sais mec tu sais et
ça c'est génial tu as talons la voulais
juste te dire qu très admiratif pour
qu'on ne fait pas assez ça ça fait
tellement de bien entendre ou à dire
c'est quelque chose de merveilleux
et lors de ces soirées de ces rencontres
que j'organise avec ces gens inspirants
on a eu des astrophysiciens des
chercheurs au cnrs des philosophes des
auteurs tous des anciens négociateurs
auraient enfin c'est la liste est
infinie ça va ça couvre un moment tous
les domaines il se passe des caisses de
résonance
ça change la vie de certaines personnes
par exemple on a organisé une soirée
voilà qui s'appelait voyage dans les
étoiles avec l'astrophysicien christophe
galfard c'était une soirée incroyable
vous pouvez voir il y avait des bougies
avaient des sublimes slide de l'univers
du big bang des étoiles et christophe
galfard a su à ce moment-là transmettre
sa passion reconnecter nous amener vers
son univers ouvrir les coulisses de son
univers et est généreux avec ça et le
diffuser à tous les gens dans la salle
est ce que je ne savais pas c'est que là
j'ai réveillé la passion d'un petit
garçon dans cette salle qui était devenu
adulte
quelques jours plus tard il m'a appelé
et m'a dit tiffany merci
merci pourquoi parce que ça fait un nom
que pour moi la vie est dure et
compliqué je me bats pour tous je me
bats dans mon couple
je le bats dans mon travail c'est voilà
c'est une guerre il ya des périodes
comme ça riait des moments dans la vie
où tu es c'est génial tout va bien plus
d'autres moments où tout s'enchaîne
c'est comme ça passe tous par là lui
était précisément dans une phase
difficile
il m'a dit cette soirée a permis de
reconnecter avec une passion que j'avais
oublié qu'ils étaient s'inquiéter
l'astrophysique
quand j'étais petit j'avais des étoiles
s'est passé vous avez ça met des étoiles
qu'on colle au plafond qui s'illumine la
nuit j'avais ça lisais des livres sur le
sujet j'avais un télescope je regardais
les étoiles et ça me faisait
complètement tripes et je partais lanmou
enlève et c'était merveilleux
eva grâce à cette soirée ça reconnecter
avec ça et depuis j'ai replongé j'ai
racheté plein de vivre sur le sujet et
pour mes 40 ans j'ai demandé à tous mes
amis de m'acheter un télescope géant
super puissants qu'ils pouvaient aller
voir hyper long et ça dès que ça va pas
dans ma vie je me reconnecte à ça et je
me mets à rêver à évadés et à
reconnecter avec ma passion et c'est
très important
il ya une autre soirée comme ça qui
était avec bernard werber
vous le connaissez sûrement qui est
l'auteur des fourmis entre autres
bernard c'est aussi quelqu'un de
passionné qui adore son métier qui ne
cesse d'apprendre ça c'est quelque chose
de très très important aussi c'est que
aujourd'hui
moi qui suis autodidacte on se frotte
aux diktats ou super diplômés
il ya plus de différences tous on doit
apprendre en permanence on peut plus
rester dans un rail dans quelque chose
de précis de défini on doit tout
remettre en question
s'adapter et lui nous a donné ce goût là
et l'appareil
une femme sophie m'appelle quelques
jours après en me disant il s'est passé
un truc
il a révélé mon désir il a réveillé mon
désir j'avais complètement oublié
enfin c'est pas qu'elle avait oublié
c'est qu'elle n'arrivait pas l
procrastine est depuis des années pour
écrire son premier roman
elle avait peur elle croyait de trouille
comme on peut tous avoir peur elle avait
peur et tout d'un coup ses mots à lui
ont su lui parler ça raisonnée ça a créé
cet écho cet écho à créer un impact elle
est rentrée elle a écrit jusqu'à 6h du
matin elle m'a appelé quelques jours
après la fuite de chapitres et je lui
souhaite que son roman soit édité et
qu'elle-même ensuite puisse en parler et
partager son aventure
une troisième rencontre avec le génial
explorateur jean louis etienne jean
louis etienne c'est le premier homme à
avoir atteint le pôle nord en solitaire
c'est pas rien en solitaire ça veut dire
que les dangers sont présents en
permanence
il peut se faire bouffer par un ours il
peut tomber dans l'eau glacée et moyens
en deux secondes
il peut s'endormir et ne jamais se
réveiller il ya tous ces dangers la lui
c'est qu'on sujet c'est l'instinct de
survie s'est réveillée justement cette
par animal qu'on a tous pour reconnecter
avec le danger et je crois que c'est
très à propos puisque aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de danger partout mais c'est
une chance ça veut dire qu'il faut
réveiller cet instinct comme ça de
survie de encore une fois de se
réadapter de retrouver de nouvelles
règles du jeu tout le temps il ne faut
jamais lâcher et cette rencontre on
n'était pas nombreux on devait être 25
autour d'un dîner ils avaient prévu de
parler de certains thèmes
sauf que tout d'un coup il ya eu cette
espèce de truc particulier qui fait
partie des grands des grands plaisirs de
l'ajustement de la 2de du live de la
transmission en direct c'est que tout
d'un coup il a lâché son masque il n'a
pas du tout parlé tes sujets et nous a
fait nous a donné une leçon de vie il
nous a parlé avec le coeur hélas ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ça pas changer la
vie d'une personne ou sur une connexion
particulière c'est qui nous a tous
transmis des choses tellement belle
tellement vrai tellement authentique
qu'on est tous que sorti la pari gagné
on avait tous accrochés notre char à une
étoile
et là j'ai gagné là je suis la plus
heureuse du monde quand ça arrive
et ah pardon hop le jeu on revient là et
donc par rapport à ça
moi j'avais une question à vous poser
tous et que j'aimerai en tout cas vous
vous posiez en sortant de stocker que ça
réfléchissent pour comprendre un peu
mieux justement où vous allez qui vous
êtes et retrouver cette connexion là
avec vous même qui admire et vous est-ce
que c'est clair dans votre tête
si c'est pas clair il faut trouver
essayer de comprendre inspirer vos
quotidiens qui admire et vous mais
surtout pourquoi pourquoi vous les
admirer et continuer de chercher ne le
lâchez pas inspirez vous admirez et
surtout accrocher votre char à une
étoile
merci
[Applaudissements]